yep that's Jason Momoa Sam's tux inside
the Golden Globes the 40-year old actor
was caught having a real moment during
the 77th annual awards show on Sunday
and we are living for it the hilarious
outfit change was spotted while
Succession star Brian Cox was heading to
the stage to accept his award for Best
Actor in a TV series Jason that can be
seen behind him clearly relaxing into
the night seemingly unaware he was going
to be shown on TV rocking a tank top
with his hair pulled back in his
signature man bun before shedding his
expensive duds Jason turned heads while
on the red carpet in this green velvet
Tom Ford coat Valentino pants
accessorizing the look with a Cartier
watch and custom pin worth 250,000
dollars how much does it
[Music]
all right we're borrowing it
Jason was joined by wife lisa bonet who
was matching her hubby in a green
ethereal Fendi couture gown
Jason eventually put his tomforde coat
back on and took his hair down while
presenting with stepdaughter zoe kravitz
but fans were already all about it on
social media calling Jason a legend for
wearing casual attire in a room full of
fancy suits
et spoke with Jason and Lisa ahead of
the memorable moment while on the red
carpet excuse me I can't take it you
both look stunning and you look like an
old fairy I'm very old fairy now you're
presenting I am with my beautiful
stepdaughters always yeah so it's a
family it's gonna be amazing yeah I'm
very excited thank you
so we just saw Kate coming up here did
you yeah do you have the fun things for
me I do absolutely good yeah okay
you're all over all over the place we
know that I know I see you soon you will
be seeing me soon I will be see you soon
Ozzy today with the kids that is close
to it's great the new video came out
today right yeah so you're just gonna
have fun and what's your family yeah
it's beautiful
[Music]